Wir heben ab, das Fun steht für Spaß, ich dachte Häuser können brennen, doch ich hab mich verdammt.
Wir trinken heute Booster und ein Winky sagt Puh, der startet so tief wie euer Tinder-Konsum. Wir heben ab, das Fun steht für Spaß, ich dachte Häuser können brennen, doch ich hab mich verdammt. Es sind Tini und Hitzler, der gerade das spricht, der beste Podcast im Land, mehr aber auch nicht. Einen wunderschönen guten Morgen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das ist das Podcast,
UFO Podcast, natürlich wieder mit dabei, entspannt, gut gelaunt und pünktlich, Stefan T. Hallo, du spielst darauf an, dass er ein paar Minuten zu spät war, es tut mir sehr leid, glaube ich, ich freue mich auch. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-UFO, ihr hört es schon, an dem kleinen Heizofen, der Winter ist wieder an unserem kleinen Heizöfchen in unserem kleinen Kellerraum. Der immer so eine ganz unangenehme Werbe macht, so eine heisses Metall, heisser Staubwärme. Heisser Staub, ja, was immer noch brandt, riech sofort. Ja, ich glaube, das ist heisser Staub, das ist so das erste Mal, wenn man im Winter die Heizung anmacht und der ganze Staub, der sich auf den Heizkörpern angesammelt hat, warm wird, dann weiß man, es ist wieder Winterzeit. Es ist wieder Winter, ja. Wir haben nebenan einen Schneideraum und da dringt immer Kaminluft rein. Ja? Ja. Welchem Kamin denn? Von den Wohnungen gegenüber. Die machen dann Kamin an und dann kommt Kaminluft. Nicht nach außen wird es geleitet, wie in allen anderen Wohnungen, sondern bei uns in den Schneideraum. Einfach in das nächste Haus neben rein. Und es werden da reihenweise Leute wahnsinnig. Und wir haben halt in jedem Raum sitzt ein Cutter und schneidet in einer Folge. Und in meiner Weise sind immer alle glücklich. Voll Podcastsuchen meinst du? Von der Serie, die wir gerade machen. Aha. Und lustigerweise sind alle immer beim Gucken immer sehr positiv und cool. Außer in dem Raum, wo du ganz schnell müde wirst und einfach raus willst. Und der Cutter sich immer wundert, warum man warum man keine Notes der Folge bekommt. Und ich bin mal gespannt, ob man später merkt, in welchem Raum diese Folge geschnitten wurde, weil einfach so ein katastrophaler Einbruch in der Qualität stattzufinden ist, weil Dinge werden zweimal geschnitten, weil man auch vergisst Dinge durch diesen Kohlemonoxid-Kack. So in hundert Jahren, wenn irgendwie dann die How-to-Sale-Drugs-Forschung, wie wenn jedes Kind in der Schule How-to-Sale-Drugs anschauen muss. Ja, wie die Buddenbrucks damals. Und man genau versucht zu analysieren. Oh, das hat der Jahr, mein grosser Bruder hat das auch schon gemacht, der geht so, das wäre ganz langweilig. Oh Gott, was wollte uns Herr Tietze mit diesem Bild sagen? Oh ja, mein Gott. Mein Gott, grab ihn aus und frag ihn doch, nachdem er so jung gestorben ist. Können wir nicht, wie er Buddenbrucks lesen, wer jung gestor ist. Wann ist er gestorben? Naja, man weiß es nicht genau. Es gibt verschiedene Mysterien um seinen Tod. Ist er entweder 2027 in Wien oder 2026 in Budapest gestorben? Warum auf jeden Fall in Wien? Man ist klar, dass er in Wien gestorben ist. Hat er viel in Wien gemacht? Schön auf dem Prater. Entweder ist er vom Riesenrad runtergefallen oder hat sich an Zuckerwatte überfressen, man weiß es nicht genau. Beides möglich, oder er ist glücklich in Argentinien. Ja, aber das ist das, was mich an Heizung immer stört, dass Leute nicht das meiste aus Heizung rausmachen. Also dass sie Heizung einfach nur als Wärmeobjekt benutzen, dabei sind Heizungen so viel mehr. Was sind Heizungen mehr als Wärmeobjekt? Leute unterschätzen, was es für ein unglaublicher Vorteil sein kann, einfach ein heißes Objekt in der Wohnung zu haben. Zum Beispiel, um Dinge aufzuwärmen. Also jetzt nicht um die Luft aufzuwärmen, sondern Dinge aufzuwärmen. Nein, keine Ahnung, du machst dir irgendwie einen schönen Tee oder so und stellst ihn dann auf der Heizung ab, damit er länger warm bleibt. Oder natürlich der Klassiker, abends man kommt nach Hause, hat einen stressigen Tag, erst mal ein Glas Nutella für eine Stunde auf die Heizung und dann schön extra einfach, einfach weglöffelt. Das ist samtig zart. Ich war jetzt erst mal auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt und habe mir erst mal einen schönen Nutella-Crep gegessen. Oh, herrlich. Schön mit Bananen drin? Ne, ohne Bananen. Ich bin einfach plain Nutella-Guy. Aber Puderzucker. Aber ich bin immer sauer über die Menge, die sie drauf machen. Entweder weil es viel zu viel ist oder weil es zu wenig ist. Es gibt keine perfekte Nutellamenge. Und mittlerweile kostet das der Index, an dem ich immer erkenne, wie die Währung voranscheidet, ein Nutellacrepp bei 3,50 Euro. Echt? Der C-i, der Crepe-Index ist auf 3,50 Euro angestiegen. Der NCI, der Nutella-Crep-Index, ist bei 3,50 Euro. Als ich damals auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt war in einer Schulzeit, war er bei 2,20 Euro. Wow, wie sich das entwickelt. Aber ich meine, ich kriege immer noch 70 Crebs im Monat bezahlt. Also da ändert sich gar nichts. Da ist irgendwie wieder nichts dahinter. Da hören die da oben wieder nicht hin. Ja, ein variabler Mindestlohn. Warum muss man alle paar Jahrzehnte über den Mindestlohn diskutieren? Warum sagt man nicht einfach so, der steigt jedes Jahr um fünf Prozent, Stefan T. Was neu ist, ist nämlich, dass wir uns mit unserem neuen Geld, also Werbeeinnahmen... Das spricht dir überhaupt nicht an auf politische Themen. Doch. Mal irgendwie so ein politisches Thema mal ausdiskutieren, mal in die Tiefe gehen. Da legst du sofort wieder ab. Hier gibt jetzt keine Argumente mehr. Steht auf und was möchtest du? Guck, ich wollte dir das andere Heizöfchen zeigen, was wir haben. Kämpfen die so ein bisschen, weil wir haben einen winzigen Heizofen auf der einen Seite des Raumes und einen riesigen schwarzen, wie so ein Plasmat-Fernseher, auf der anderen Seite des Raumes und die kämpfen so gegeneinander. Ja, ja, mit Wärme. Obwohl der Kleine sich auch denkt, warum soll ich mich anstrengen, wenn ich so ein riesen Rödel hier drin habe. Ja, so ein neumodernes Ding auch, was wahrscheinlich keine Geräusche macht. Das müssen wir mal einstecken vielleicht. Aber war der Kleine zuerst und die Leute dachten sich, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Wir brauchen mehr. Oder der Grosse war zuerst und die dachten sich, vielleicht noch so ein, zwei Grad mehr, dann wäre ich zufrieden. Ich glaube, die Leute waren mal wieder unzufrieden und wollten dann wieder mehr, mehr, mehr, aber ich glaube, der Kleine hätte es perfectly getan. Es ist perfekt. Ich hatte ja lange einen Luftentfeuchter, weil ich habe ja lange meine Jugendjahre in einem Kellerzimmer verbracht und da ist mal Wasser reingekommen. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das gibt, weil alle kaufen sich immer Luftbefeuchter. Ne, ne, ne, ne, und das Coolste ist natürlich, wenn du einen Luftbefeuchter und einen Luftentfeuchter im selben Raum hast und die beide so, kann man, sag mal, hallo, hallo, was mache ich hier eigentlich den ganzen Tag? Hey, ganz kurz, nein, kommen wir alle zusammen. Oder sie strengen sich so richtig an, so, komm schon, komm schon, Luftfeuchtigkeit hoch. Ich will mich immer interessieren, weil eine dieser Tätigkeiten, ich habe keine Grundlage dafür für diese Behauptung, aber es ist in Sicherheit Energieaufwendigkeit. Ja, ja, ja, eine ist Bullshit, die andere ist okay. Die andere ist Bullshit, die andere ist super schwierig. Ich frage mich mal jetzt, wenn die mit der gleichen Leistung arbeiten, wird das Zimmer eher feuchter oder eher trockener? Schwer zu sagen. Das kann ich dir nicht sagen, aber wie gesagt, damals hat es einmal stark geregnet und mein Kellerzimmer ist so ein bisschen überflutet, ein bisschen, und es war ein bisschen ein Problem, und dann war vor allem der Teppichboden komplett nass. Ja. Und das ist halt blöd, weil der Teppichboden ja auch unter Regalen ist und so. Ja, das ist scheiße. Und du kriegst das nicht wirklich trocken. Und deswegen war unsere Lösung, also die Lösung, die meine Eltern und ich abgesprochen haben, die vor allem involviert hat, dass ich möglichst wenig arbeiten möchte, um dieses Problem zu lösen, war, nee, wir besorgen Luftentfeuchter. weil wenn die Luft trocken ist, sehr trocken, dann trocknet dir automatisch alles, was im Raum ist, ohne dass man es jetzt explizit trocknen muss. Ich bin kein Luftfeuchtigkeitsexperte, aber ich behaupte, das ist auch ein bisschen Quatsch. Vielleicht ist es Bullshit, aber ich war bis zuletzt hoch fasziniert von diesem Objekt, weil das ist ein weißer Kasten, den du in den Raum stellst mit Strom und der rödelt drei Stunden lang und dann hast du unten so einen Behälter, wo einfach Wasser drin ist. Der zieht Wasser aus der Luft. Und ich mir dachte, warum hat man solche Dinge nicht zum Beispiel irgendwie in der Wüste dabei oder so? In Afrika. Also ich meine, klar, die Gründe sind hoch, hoher Energieverbrauch und da ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel Feuchtigkeit in der Luft, weil es sehr trocken ist. Beides gute Gründe. Trotzdem denke ich mir, bevor man Wasser überall mit hin nimmt, kann man doch auch einfach so einen Luftentfeuchter mitnehmen. So irgendwie im Weltraum oder so auf fremden Planeten, wo es vielleicht so ein bisschen, na gut, wenn es kein Wasser gibt. Aber stimmt der Planet nicht aus, wenn du den zu lange anlässt? Ich hätte mir ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist ein bisschen problematisch, vor allem du hast ja dann dieses Wasser, das darf man auf gar keinen Fall trinken.
Hast du so eimerweise Wasser oder hast du nur so ein Pfützchen? Nee, das schon, also was heißt Eimer, wenn es mal so den ganzen Tag läuft und es feucht war, da geht das. Ich hatte auch die Hochleistungsvariante. Das ist wirklich die mit schönem Diesel, deren auch ich durch. Mit dem Dieselmotor. Ja, der durchballert. Luft war rein, aber starker Dieselgeruch. Ja, ja, genau. Aber auf dem Behälter, wo das Wasser gesammelt wurde, stand auch gross drauf, nicht trinken.
Und ich war natürlich immer verleitet. Hast du drunter geschrieben, was soll ich denn sonst damit machen? Was stand da drunter? Ich habe drunter geschrieben, warum? Ja, und was haben die antwortet? Die haben geschrieben, ja, weil das ist destilliertes Wasser, das saugt dir das Salz aus den Gliedern, du Bastard. Nee, Bastard war die Firma. Das stimmt. Da ist die Vertan jetzt. Ist eine Altdeutsche, ist Liebherr Bastard. Bastard war die Firma. Scheiße, die Vertanier ist. Ist eine Altdeutsche, ist es Liebherr Bastard. Bastard Luftentfeuchter. Von Heinrich Bastard gegründet, sein Sohn Rudolf Bastard übernommen. Was es alles für einen Quatsch gibt auf der Welt, Luftbefeuchter, das haben viele, das habe ich schon häufig gesehen in Kinderzimmern dieser Welt. Was ich nicht, ich verstehe ja eh nicht, wie diese ganzen Dinge funktionieren, aber zumindest kann man die Wikipedia-Artikel lesen, man versteht einigermaßen, wie das funktioniert. Jetzt hat meine Mom bei sich zu Hause, da muss jetzt die Heizung erneuert werden. Und mein Onkel, der auch in dem Bereich arbeitet, hat jetzt eine Brennstoffzellenheizung empfohlen, die ihre eigene, da würde meine Mutter ihren eigenen Strom herstellen. Aber mit Brennstoffzellen? Brennstoffzellen, Uran oder was? Ich habe keine Ahnung gehabt, habe ich auch immer noch nicht. Ich habe den Wikipil-Adikel gelesen und ich verstehe gar nichts davon. Vielleicht kannst du mir helfen, aber die Idee ist, dass man halt Strom spart natürlich und Geld spart, indem man seinen eigenen Strom in gewisser Weise erzeugt, mit einer Brennstoffzelle, die man in seiner Wohnung installiert. Aber da wird was verbrannt, oder wie? Eine Brennstoffzelle ist eine galvanische Zelle. Und hier möchte ich schon mal eine Kritik äussern. Da weiss man schon, dieser Artikel geht in eine ganz andere Richtung. Und du klickst auf galvanisch und siehst, diese Technik wird in Brennstoffen eingesetzt. Ja, cool. Wobei, wenn ich galvanische Zelle, ja, zum Beispiel in Brennstoffzelle. Oh gut, die chemische Reaktionsenergie eines kontinuierlich zugeführten Brennstoffes und eines Oxidationsmittels in elektrische Energie wandelt. Ein Oxidationsmittel, das klingt, also da wird irgendwas verbrannt, aber wahrscheinlich nicht so mit so einer Flamme, sondern irgendwie so chemisch krass. Ja genau, und eines kontinuierlich zugeführten Brennstoffes, aber es klingt beides nach Dingen, die zugeführt werden müssen. Aber was ist der Brennstoff? Das wäre interessant zu wissen. Wir finden das raus, Brennstoffzellenheizung, ich habe es noch nicht ganz verstanden. Ja, wir werden wahrscheinlich viele Mails bekommen von Energieexperten, die jetzt genau erklären, warum das falsch ist. Die Leute skippen oft den Erklärt-Part, sondern gehen direkt über in, ey, mach das auf gar keinen Fall, da habe ich richtig viel verloren, das ist richtig umweltschädlich. Da Funktionsprinzip der Brennstoffzellenheizung in einem sogenannten Reformer, klingt erst wie Reaktor, ehrlich gesagt, leicht andere Wörter als Atomkraftwerk, wird das Erdgas mit Wasserdampf gemischt. Dabei entstehen Kohlenmonoxid und Wasserstoff. In der Brennstoffzelle reagiert dieser Wasserstoff zusammen mit Sauerstoff aus der Luft zu Wasser. So, dann haben wir Wasser. Hä? Ja, ich verstehe es nicht, ich würde mich echt freuen, wenn da irgendwie ein aufgeklärter Beitrag kommt. Ich nutze es im Podcast mittlerweile auch einfach, um aus privaten Fragen zu haben, um Argumente zu haben, um deine Mutter davon zu überzeugen, dann doch lieber irgendwie schön Fernwärme oder was zu machen. Nee, um ehrlich zu sein, ich habe richtig Bock auf einen Brennstoffzettel in meiner Heimat. Ist schon ganz cool, kann ja sein, dass alles verstrahlt ist. Schön geil, wenn Carmen dann einfach so runtergeht und das Haus meiner Mom einfach glüht so komplett grün. Ja, aber was ich auch cool finde, ist das Konzept von Fernwärme, wo man einfach Wärme direkt überträgt. Ich glaube, man hat dann so einen langen Metallstab vom Kraftwerk nach Hause. Wie so ein Dosentelefon. Ja, wie so ein Dosentelefon. Du schickst halt die Wärme da durch und wenn da jemand drauf tritt, dann ist halt abgeschnürt und dann kommt nichts an bei dir zu Hause. Ja, wenn ich so ein Obdachlose dann drauflege, zum Beispiel auch, weil es schön warm ist. Das passiert immer wieder. Es ist mauschelig warm. Ja, mauschelig. Schön mauschelig warm. Ich hoffe, ihr habt eine schöne Zeit da draußen und wickelt euch schön ein in euren Decken. Deckchen. Aber die Menschen sind eingepackt. Auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt habe ich das auch beobachtet. Die Menschen sind eingemummelt und eingepackt, haben sich ihre Mützchen aufgesetzt, dann haben die so dicke Jacken angezogen. Ja, Handschuhe an, eine Bommelmütze. Aber man sieht dann auch, Menschen sind irgendwie auch so ein bisschen, wirken so unbeholfen süss in der Winterzeit. Man merkt, die sind nicht für diese Gefilde gemacht. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, man lässt so ein bisschen, weil im Sommer ist ja immer so, okay, Bikinifigur, Fashion, irgendwie was ziehe ich an, cool an Strand irgendwie. Aber im Winter ist es anscheinend allem scheißegal, wie sie aussehen, weil eh alle aussehen wie irgendwie so aufgepluderte Gänse, wie dann irgendwie so eine Bommelmütze, wo halt so normale Attraktivitätsstandards wie irgendwie cool oder sexy einfach über Bord gebraucht werden und man einfach wie ein Bommelkind aussieht. Sommer ist cool, sexy, Sonnenbrille, Bikinifrisur, Sixpack. Im Winter ...
Bikinifrisur.
Sorry, tschuldigung.
Und im Winter ist es Pragmatismus. Ja, total. Klassischer Pragmatismus. Süss ist, glaube ich, eher. Also, was im Sommer sexy ist als Standard. Ich glaube, man will dann eher auf Richtung süss. Man will diese dicken Weihnachtspullis mit dem Sonntaglaus drauf. Man will sich Bommelmtzen, Bommel, Bommel, ja genau, hin und her.
Die dicken Fäustlinge irgendwie, man ist komplett eingeschränkt, man kann nichts mehr tun.
Einen dicken Schal, der bis nach oben ein bisschen Augen hingeht, also man, ich glaube, der Attraktivitätsstandard geschwenkt zu süss hinüber, man versucht eher süss zu sein.
Es gibt ja auch Wintermoden und so, also es gibt ja auch Leute, die sich darüber Gedanken machen, verdammt nochmal, wie kriegen wir es hin, dass nicht alle aussehen wie zu grosse Kinder, die dann irgendwie so rumhampeln die ganze Zeit, auch die Schneehose oder solche Sachen. Schneehose, Stiefel, Schneestiefel. Und dann auch Schals ist ja für mich, also ich habe einen Schal, den benutze ich sehr selten, es ist immer schwer das Timing herauszufinden, wenn man Schal benutzt. Ich verbinde dich sehr häufig mit Schal, ehrlich gesagt. Wirklich? Ja, in meinem Kopf hast du meistens einen Schal. Ja, weil ich einmal in diesen ersten Fotos bei der Masterclass einen Schal hatte. Da kenne ich dich ja her. Das ist immer so, der erste Eindruck hängt, weil ich hatte eine Erkältung und hatte meinen Hufflepuff-Schal an und seitdem bin ich bekannt als der Tag einfach. Der Kranke Vollidiot. Der Kranke mit dem Schal. Aber ehrlich gesagt, es ist nicht clever, bei so einem ersten Eindruck etwas zu tragen, was du sonst nie wieder trägst. Das stimmt schon. Man hat ja oft erste Eindrücke nicht als erste Eindrücke im Kopf. Man denkt so, ich gehe da einfach hin und stellte später fest, verdammt, ich krieg nie wieder diese Rolle los, einfach nur weil ich am ersten Tag irgendwie ein bisschen heisser war und dann einfach ein bisschen, ey Leute, und alle denken sich so, oh, cooler Typ. Und wenn sie dich imitieren, holen sie immer, hallo, ich bin der Florentin. Ja, du hast am ersten Tag einen dicker Nerd, seitdem bist du das. Ja, dicker, kranker, schniefner Nerd. Obwohl du eigentlich so ein super Partyhengst bist. Ja, ich war ein cooler Typ damals, aber habe es irgendwie nicht auf die Leinwand bekommen. Ja genau, darauf kommt es nämlich an. Also seid am besten jeden Tag so, wie ihr seid, dann kommt ihr nicht in die Bredouille. Ja, und habt vor allem vor Augen erste Eindrücke. Denkt euch, oh, ich treffe heute das erste Mal den neuen Freund von meiner Freundin. Würdet ihr euch heute Morgen diese Bommelmütze anziehen? Genau, deswegen sollten Weihnachtsmärkte auch keine ersten Eindrücke sein, weil man trägt Rest des Jahres keine Bommelmütze. Man trinkt Glühwein, man hat irgendwie Nutella am Mundwinkel, man hat irgendwie so eine Käsekreiner in der Hand, wo man irgendwie das heiße... Ah, okay, das sind jetzt wieder diese lokale Begriffe überall anders.
Ja, da habe ich immer Spaß dran.
In Bayern heißen diese Würste mit Käseschleim drin, heißen Käsekreiner von Kreinen weinen.
Also als würden die Käse weinen, was ein sehr romantisches Bild ist.
Nee, das ist ein geiles Bild.
Ist auch ganz geil.
Ich würde, oh, wie kann ich Käse weinen?
Ja, ich glaube, manchmal heisst es auch Eitrige oder sowas, werden auch manchmal genannt, verschiedene Begriffe. Da trifft es ja schon ab. Ich weiß nur, dass ich dieses Objekt mit gleichermaßen Liebe und Hass besetzt habe, weil natürlich schmecken die fantastisch, aber sie sind in der Regel so dermassen heiß, dass man sie nicht direkt essen kann. und wenn man reinbeisst, einfach irgendwie heisse Käse ins Auge schiesst und man sich einfach denkt, warum tut mir das, was ich liebe, so weh und du isst es trotzdem und dein Hals brennt, aber es schmeckt trotzdem fantastisch. Ich denke, der Weihnachtsmann hat Essen quasi durchgespielt, also sowas wie Raclette, dann dieses Langosch, unglaublich toll, nein, gar nichts mit Spiessen zu tun. Aber Fleischiges? Nein, nichts mit Fleisch zu tun. Das sind diese Kartoffel... Mh, mh, mh, mh. Richtig lecker. Diese ungarische Pizzaart mit so Kartoffelteig. Unglaublich lecker. Aber viel mehr kann man auf dem Weihnachtsmann nicht machen. So im Sommer, da geht man Fußball spielen, Beachvolleyball, Skateboard, Inline-Skates, aber im Winter kannst du nur Glühwein trinken und dir überlegen, verdammt, ich habe noch nicht alle Geschenke. Es werden immer mehr Geschenke, dann kriegt irgendjemand ein Kind, irgendein Verwandter kriegt ein Kind und man denkt sich, ab welchem Alter muss man dem was schenken, was soll ich einem einjährigen Kind schenken, soll man dann wirklich dem so ein dummes Kuscheltier oder ein Schl Schlagzeug schenken oder wann in diese Regeln? Immer mal die Eltern fragen, Kinder haben
Phasen, immer die Eltern fragen, dann sagen die Dinos, kurzes Heads-up, Dino, die schenke ich
so ein steif Dino-Tier. Dann Power Rangers, dann GTA, GTA, GTA, Fortnite, Fortnite,
dann AfD-Phase, AfD, Phase, AfD, ja, ja. Was wir bräuchten, wäre so ein Geschenkeregelbuch,
so ein, so ein kleines Booklet, kann das jetzt ein Flyer sein? Ja, lass es ein Limerick sein. Ich glaube, das war mehr Regel. Die literarische Form ist jetzt erstmal zweitrangig. Wichtig ist, dass wir ein allgemein akzeptiertes Geschenkebuch haben. Menschen kriegen ab dem sechsten Lebensjahr Geschenke bis zum neunzigsten Lebensjahr. Menschen kriegen, also folgender Verwandtschaftsgrad muss erreicht sein, damit man in Geschenk Pflicht ist. Und der Flyer ist nicht mehr, ist voll. Ist voll, okay. Flyer Teil zwei. Ich glaube, es ist ein zweihundertseitiges Buch, um ehrlich zu sein, mindestens. Es könnte ein Foliant werden oder ein Almanach, man weiß nicht genau, es könnte in verschiedene Richtungen gehen. Ich glaube, wir müssen eine Tabelle haben, auf jeden Fall mit Verwandtschaftsgrad und dann Geldbetrag, der auszugeben ist. Geldbetrag und vor allem, also es gibt ja Geschenkpflicht und es gibt Geschenk okay und Geschenk nicht okay. So, es gibt einen gewissen Verwandtschaftsgrad, da ist es nicht mehr okay, Geschenke zu schenken, da wird es gruselig. Irgendwie, wenn du, keine Ahnung, wirklich der Stiefvater, der Chef, dessen Assistentin, sein, ihr Bruder und so weiter, dann nochmal ein Geschenk, sagt, es ist weird irgendwie, dann wird es komisch, aber es gibt ja so einen Graubereich, wo es okay ist und wo man einfach sagt, so du kannst, aber du musst nicht. Ja. Lieber nicht. Lieber nicht. Lass mal lieber. Lass mal lieber Bereich. Ja. Aber ansonsten der engste Bereich und da muss man schenken und man muss auf jeden Fall die Geldbeträge festlegen, sonst kommt es auch, also das ist aber auch eigentlich einigermaßen geschickt gemacht von der Gesellschaft, man wächst da so rein. Ich habe so die Erfahrung gemacht, Cousin, Cousine, 30 Euro Geschenke, 35 Euro bis 50 vielleicht und dann noch oft oder halt Geldscheine verpackt mit
Messi, Toffee,
sowas. Ja, ja, ja, aber was auch, was ja super
ist eigentlich, was die Idealsituation ist, ist, wenn sich
jemand was von dir wünscht.
Aber, angenommen jetzt jemand, der dir
sehr nahe ist, wünscht sich was von
dir und dann denkst du dir, yes,
wunderbar, ich muss mir keine
Gedanken mehr machen über diese Person,
sie hat sich was gewünscht, dann schaust du das, was
sie sich gewünscht hat an,
es kostet acht Euro. Ja.
Denkst du dir,
fuck shit.
Einerseits,
sie hat sich es ja gewünscht,
also das ist ja das, was sie erwartet, diese
Person. Auf der anderen Seite,
normalerweise wäre dieser Betrag zu gering,
also muss eigentlich noch was dazu, aber was, das hat sie sich ja nicht gewünscht. Jetzt bist du in einer noch grösseren Predulie, weil du nicht nur noch ein zusätzliches Geschenk brauchst, sondern eins, das wiederum den Preis ausgleicht. Du brauchst theoretisch dann, die Amazon-Kunden kauften auch Buttons, weil da hast du ungefähr eine Richtung, was noch da herrscht. Vor allem Auf einmal müsste sich auf jeden Fall, das Problem an Weihnachtsgeschenken ist ja, dass es eigentlich immer so ein großer Aufbau ist, Stress, Stress, Stress. Dann ist Weihnachten und dann vergisst man alles sofort, weil man will sich jetzt ein Jahr lang nicht mehr beschäftigen. Man müsste da viel mehr Buch führen. Was habe ich letztes Jahr geschenkt, wie kam das Geschenk an? Ein Debriefing. Genau, ein Debriefing. Das ist schon 27. De. Dezember Debriefing. Das Problem ist auch, dass Silvester und Weihnachten zu nah beieinander hängen. Das sage ich schon seit Jahren. Das ist ein Riesenfehler. Ja, ich weiss, du sagst das seit Jahren laut und du hast ja auch deine Partei gegründet in der Hinsicht. Ich finde nur, was wir immer vergessen, auch in deinem Trubel, der 27. ist der Debriefing-Tag, wir müssen über Weihnachten reden. Die ganze Familie setzt sich noch was zusammen, wäre mein Vorschlag.
Alle nochmal, auch mit ähnlichen Traditionen.
Da gibt es einen Baum,
hast du dann eine Birke,
spezielle Lieder,
die Briefing-Lieder und so,
ein sehr moderner Feiertag.
Im Radio laufen bestimmte Songs.
Und dann lässt man sich zusammen und sagt,
wie war Weihnachten dieses Jahr, was hat uns gefallen,
Posts und Cons, Essen, weil jedes Jahr haben wir ein paar Wochen vor Weihnachten immer einen Familien Get Together, ihr erinnert euch die Fondue Storyline?
Get together, get together.
Und da besprechen wir immer, was es zu essen gibt Weihnachten.
Und niemand erinnert sich, wo wir letztes Jahr Weihnachten gefeiert haben, und niemand erinnert sich, was gegessen wurde. Gema. Wenn angerufen wird, kann man ja nichts dafür, liebe Gema. Das stimmt eigentlich, ja. Es sind klingeltöne feine raus. Du weißt nicht mehr, was du gegessen hast. Du weißt vor allem nicht mehr, wie es war. Und das ist total bescheuert. Man vergisst sofort am 27. Weil niemand sagt, an Weihnachten, das Essen ist gerade aber furchtbar. Ne, ne, ne. Du brauchst zwei Tage Abstand, ein bisschen abkühlen, die Kinder haben das Lego aufgebaut, irgendwie ist es gegen die Wand gefahren, die Hälfte ist runtergefallen. Die meisten Dinge sind kaputt. Das wichtigste Teil fehlt. Die Karrierabahn ist schon mehrfach entgleist und dem Hund ins Gesicht, der gerade hinzukommen ist, der Hund ist blind geworden. Man überlegt sich, was soll man jetzt mit dem machen, in den Ofen irgendwie aussetzen irgendwo. Das sind die unangenehmen Teile des Weihnachtsfestes, die dann dazukommen. Wir hatten jetzt lange Zeit, als wir die Serie zweite Staffel geschrieben haben, kam dann irgendwann eine liebe Kollegin dazu, die dann andere Aufgaben übernommen hat. Da kommen dann auch viele productionelle Aufgaben hinzu. Und die hat einen Hund dabei. Einen Hund. Und zwar nicht nur irgendeinen Hund, sondern einen blinden Mops, der so alt ist wie die Sonne. Unglaublich alt. Und der hat gestunken, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Also wirklich, der war, ich habe sie gerochen, die Kollegin, schon einfach anhand ihres Hundes, wusste so, ah, okay, heute ist sie da. Und das ist halt furchtbar, wir haben irgendwann dieses Äquivalent aufgemacht, das ist wie, als ob du so einen stinkenden Müllsack mitbringst und den da hinstellst und sagst, es ist okay, wenn mein stinkender Müllsack heute hierbei ist. Das ist die gleiche Idee. Du verlangst das gleiche von deinen Kollegen, wie wenn du einen stinkenden Sack mitbringst. Aber es ist halt dieser Hund, der lebt, der auch noch dazu führt, dass ich halt ab und zu mal raus muss mit dem, wenn man die Häuser ziehen muss. Sag mal, Gassi gehen, sag mal. So, und dann habe ich sie lange nicht gesehen, die war dann auch relativ früh raus, und dann am Abschlussfest habe ich sie getroffen und sie hat gesagt, ah, und dann habe ich ja, dann kann man ja endlich mal wieder so Sachen machen, die so liegen bleiben, während man Stress hat. Zum Beispiel habe ich mich endlich mal um die Hautkrankheit meines Hundes gekümmert. Und ich habe gesagt, was, ja, er hatte übrigens eine Hautkrankheit. Er hat sich ja bestimmt gefragt, was dieser Geruch war. Und alle im Raum, ja, das haben wir uns gefragt. Alle haben es unisono gesagt. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, ich war beim Tierarzt mit dem und alle so, what the fuck, das kannst du doch nicht, ja dann erst machen. Das ist doch, it's the condition, du musst es doch machen. Und dann hatte er eine furchtbare Hautbakterienkrankheit und sie musste ihn einmal einschamponieren und das war's. Das ist ihr nach dem Projekt aufgefallen, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Und wir sassen da monatelang mit so einem stinkenden Müllsack. Oh Gott. Das ist wirklich grauenhaft gewesen. Das ist wirklich furchtbar. Aber wo wir gerade bei blinden Hunden waren, das war meine Gedankenkette von Kaderbahn. Also nicht blinde Hunde, sondern blinde Hunde. Blinde Hunde. Die selber nochmal einen Blindenhund bräuchten. Ja, oder einen blinden Menschen. Ja, stimmt. Aber keinen blinden Menschen, dann macht es immer wieder krise. Ich würde euch bitten, nehmt ein bisschen Rücksicht auf eure Umwelt. Also es ist schön, dass ihr euch um einen blinden Hund kümmert, aber achte vielleicht darauf, dass der nicht einfach ein stinkender Sack ist, der da rumliegt in der Ecke. Generell, wenn ihr denkt, ihr wollt ein Haustier, macht es nicht einfach. Es ist immer besser, wenn ein Haustier zu wenig gekauft wird, als wenn eins zu viel gekauft wird. Wenn ihr eine Wohnung habt, die zu klein ist, wenn ihr keine Zeit habt, lasst es einfach. Du bist gegen Haustiere, ganz gegen Haustiere. Naja, wenn sie in einem richtigen Umfeld aufwachsen, schon, aber irgendwie, manche, ist es auch schwierig. Aber man auch nicht weiß, was an den Tieren vorgeht. Manchmal denkt man sich, kriegt der irgendwas mit, so ein Hund, checkt der irgendwas, checkt der, dass der ein scheiß Leben hat gerade oder kriegt der nichts mit. Man weiss es nicht. Der blinde, stinkende, uralte Mops, der hat so eine Altersweisheit auch, der weiss gerade, das ist es gewesen. Ich stimme vor, dass so eine Sartre-artige Stimme in ihm innewohnt, der sich so eigentlich am liebsten anzünden würde. Wir werden schon tot geboren. Genau. Ja, so mit dem französischen Akzent auch die ganze Zeit überlegt, wie die Welt einordnen soll. Ich glaube, ich hätte ein echtes Problem mit einer Schildkröte als Haustier, weil ich vom ersten Tag wüsste, vom ersten Tag, Tier ist da, Baby, Baby ist da und ich weiß,ibi ist da, sie hat keinen Dreck am Stecken.
Vom ersten Tag wüsste ich genau, eines Tages schaue ich diese Schildkröte an und würde... Sie umdrehen, einfach am Rücken liegen. Einfach mal... Einfach... Ich weiss, dass ich es tue, deswegen habe ich keine, aber ich weiss, dass ich es tue, dass ich eines Tages? Aber aus so einem Aussetzer heraus, wie Leute die Angst haben, wenn sie über eine Brücke gehen, drüber zu springen, oder weil, naja, das Gesicht, was du gemacht hast, war kein Aussetzergesicht, das war völlige Absicht, kommt er noch. Es ist ein geplanter Aussetzer, du weißt, dass es passieren wird, eines Tages flippe ich den auf dem Rücken und dann irgendwann würde ich ihn auf dem Rücken flippen und so drehen, wie so ein Dreher. Wie Mario Reisel. Ja, genau. So den Breakdance lassen. Deswegen sucht euch Tiere, bei denen euch nicht instinktiv Dinge einfallen, wie man sie foltern könnte. Dann sind alle Tiere ausgegeben. Nein, klar. Da kannst du auf den Schwanz steigen, du kannst ein Flamingo irgendwie festhalten. Ich sag ja, alle Tiere sind jetzt nicht mehr vorhanden.
Ja, das stimmt. Ausweibungswürdig.
Schlange, macht mal einen Knoten rein.
Ja, natürlich machst du einen Knoten rein.
Ich würde aber wirklich... Oder so eine Brezel.
Ich würde wirklich eine Schlange Knoten machen, um zu sehen, ob die da wieder rauskommt.
Ja.
Weil das ist ja ein ernstes Problem für eine Schlange, wenn die sich einfach mal verknotet.
Und dann, was macht sie dann? Die kann sich ja nicht mehr bewegen, weil die ist ja darauf angelegt, dass sie so schlängelt du weißt nicht mal wie es funktioniert dass sie sich fort bewegt ja das ist muskelkontraktion ist mir schon klar aber fliegt einfach oder wer irgendwann so in zehn jahren alle wissenschaftler übrigens lang fliegen doch sorry ja wie die asiatischen drachen diese schlangen wo man sich denkt man kann fl, hat aber keine Flügel. Was habt ihr für unrealistische Mythologien da hinten? Wohingegen wir haben Drachen mit Flügeln, weil die Fliegen ja. Die Feuerspein. Ja, okay. Die Feuerspein. Aber die haben Flügel, um zu fliegen. Das sind aber 200 Meter Durchmesser. Aber sie haben ja Flügel, damit sie fliegen können. Eine Kollege von mir hat Bienen. Wie viele? Das weiß ich nicht. Also wirklich so neun oder zehntausend? Also wo ist da die Zahl? Sechs Bienen. Wobei, oh, ich krieg gerade eine SMS. Fünf Bienen. Nee, er hat einen Bienenstock, was ich ganz toll finde. Also du hast deinen eigenen Honig, du trägst zur Umwelt was dazu bei. Aber was ist denn so eine Zahl für einen Bienenstock? Sag mal eine Zahl. 200, 300, 500, 1000, 60, 300. Aber die sind wohl auch dann sehr, also die dezimieren sich im Winter. Das ist extrem schwer zu zählen, weil die nicht stillhalten werden, die ganz den Tag. Eins, zwei, ach komm, eins, zwei, drei. Aber eine Königin, eigentlich ist ja ein Organismus, der Bienen, sagt man ja. Ja. So, und das ist ja eine, aber das funktioniert ja auch als solcher, das eine Königin und halt dieses Volk, die teilweise so Revierkämpfe führen gegen andere. Also ist es wenn du Game of Thrones magst, toll, wenn du Honig magst, toll, ist es auf vielen Ebenen ein tolles Tier. Und wenn du die Umwelt magst, ist es toll. Und die sind halt, viele sagen dann, oh, die fliegen dann bei mir rein, ist doch blöd. Nein, die fliegen halt kilometerweit. Das ist ja vielleicht egal, ob der Nachbar einen Bienenstock hat oder jemand, der drei Kilometer von dir entfernt wurde einen Bienenstock hat. Die gesamte Stadt jetzt einen Bienenstock. Alle haben jetzt ein Problem. Du hast auch einen Bienenstock eigentlich. Ich habe auch einen Bienenstock. ja. Aber das fand ich sehr interessant. Also ich glaube, das ist noch ein gutes Haustier. Du trägst noch was dazu bei, zu der Umwelt. Ja, stimmt. Eigentlich keine schlechte Idee. Und dann den Honig. Aber der Honig hält sich ja ewig eigentlich, weil der wurde ja extra so gemacht von den Bienen, dass er sich hält. Das ist ja die Idee. Genau, das ist die Idee von Honig, ja. Eigentlich perfekt, weil so ein Hühnerei oder so, das ist ja dazu gemacht, dass es sofort schlüpft, das ist ja nicht dazu gedacht, dass man das jetzt ewig aufhält und dann Pfannkuchen macht, wohingegen Honig, man macht damit exakt das, wofür es gedacht ist, erst aufheben, irgendwann schlabbern. Werbung Geh doch zu Aldi. Aldi ist perfekt für deinen Weihnachtseinkauf. Aldi ist perfekt für meinen Weihnachtseinkauf? Da findest du alle Weihnachtsklassiker. Lebkuchen, Ente, Lamm, Kartoffelsalte und Würstchen, egal wie du deinen Weihnachten feierst, bei Aldi findest du alles. Stimmt, bei Aldi findet man natürlich alles. Und alles ist Weihnachten doch immer im Angebot. Es ist alles da, es ist im Angebot, die Preise sind gut, die Qualität ist auch gut. Und dann gibt es noch den Aldi-Ventskalender, wo man jeden Tag tolle Gewinne gewinnen kann, auf aldiventskalender.de. Weisst du, wo ich jetzt hingehe? Wohin? In Aldi. Echt? Schön für Weihnachten einkaufen. Dann sehen wir uns bei Aldi. Und jetzt viel Spaß mit der Folge. Werbung. Aber da haben wir auch schon mal drüber gesprochen. Ich verstehe nicht, aus Eiern schlüpfen keine Küken. Das sind unbefruchtete Eier, die wir essen.
Nein, die werden weggelasert. Willst du mich verarschen? Nein, in der Eierfabrik werden die weggelasert. Werden weggelasert? Die Föten, die werden abgetötet. Ansonsten würde da schon was draus schlüpfen. Vielleicht auch nicht, vielleicht müssen die auch irgendwie ausgebrütet werden. Weggelasert. Wenn die nicht ausgebrütet. Und ich habe nochmal so eine Maschine gesehen, wo die so eine Art geröntgt werden und dann röntgt damals um wieder unser Scheinverband. Oh mein Gott, fucking Detlef Röntgen. Aber naja, aber normalerweise müssen die ja ausgebrütet werden und wenn die nicht gebrütet werden, ohne Brüt kein Hüt, sagt man ja oft. Und dann kommt da kein Kük raus, ohne Brütt kein Küch. Wenn Frau Zetschgen irgendwie interstellare Reisen erfindet, fuck me. Ja, wirklich. Überlegt euch Namen einfach. Und dann bin ich rübergezwetscht zum Planeten, zu Beta 19. Wichtig, wenn ihr Apps entwickelt, überlegt euch, funktioniert die Verbformen. Hey, Dropbox, du mir das eben? Geht. Hey, wir können skypen, googeln, okay, lass uns morgen discorden.
Schwieriger. Überleg dir was. Schwieriger. Überleg dir was anderes. Tindern, perfekt.
Ich habe eine App-Idee, die ich entwickeln werde jetzt. Ich habe schon einen Namen, der Name ist, habe ich natürlich darauf untersucht, der Name ist Spit.
Spitten. Lass mal spiel das, Spitten. Spit ist der Name der App. Vielleicht gibt es den schon, das habe ich noch nicht untersucht, der Name ist Spit. Spitten. Lass mal spiel das Spitten.
Spit ist der Name der App. Vielleicht gibt es den schon, das habe ich noch nicht gecheckt.
Das ist immer das Blöde, man hat dann tolle Ideen, dann vergisst man das direkt. Aber die Idee ist ja nicht nur gut wegen dem Namen, oder?
Ne, ne, die Idee ist perfekt, aber der Name hilft.
Ich kann nicht mehr sagen, aber...
Du kannst nicht... Moritz, weil die ganzen App-Developer jetzt alle aufhauen, Moment, Sekunde, Sekunde, seid mal bitte alle ruhig! Ihr wisst, dass ihr Podcast pausieren könnt, ne? Und jetzt? Wir können auf einen ruhigeren Ort gehen. Nee, ich kann es noch nicht verraten, es ist eine Idee, die die Menschheit revolutionieren wird, es ist eine neue ... Okay, ich sag jetzt verschiedene Kategorien und du blinzelst, wenn es richtig ist. Ja, ich muss aber sehr viel blinzeln. Okay. Das habe ich immer schon gedacht bei Filmen, das wird bei mir nicht funktionieren, weil ich muss sehr oft blinzeln. Dating. Ich muss gleich blinzeln, aber das liegt nicht daran, weil es Dating ist. Okay, Finanzen. Notizen, Sport, Fitness, Gesundheit, Unterhaltung. Oh, oh, da kommt ein Unterhaltungs, irgendwas mit Unterhaltung. Ich musste wahnsinnig lange... Ist es ein Spiel, ein schönes Spiel? Nein, nein, du hast doch noch nicht die richtige Kategorieannt. Ich musste einfach blinzeln. Ich weiss doch nicht. Wissenschaft. Können wir nicht zweimal Blinzeln machen für ein Jahr? Es ist so ein Anstrengender. Er weint ihr. Komplett brennt der Augen. Mit der Augen trockenen aus. Das ist der Klassische, so erkennt man App-Developer, dass sie immer ganz verweinte Augen haben, weil sie nicht lange blinzeln haben. Blinzelt bei ... Ist es was? Ist es eine Blinzel-App? Nein. Nein. Aber das ist immer, weil du gesagt hast, Podcast pausieren. Meine, die schönste Geste, wenn ich sagen müsste, eine Geste, die ich am liebsten mag, ist das, der Raum ist gerade so laut, dass ich für mein Handy-Telefonat den Raum verlassen muss. Jeder kennt diese Geste, dieses genervte und dann, sorry, ich geh mal kurz raus, und", und dann wirklich dem Raum noch mal so einen wütenden Blick zuwerfen, weil alle im Raum Spaß haben. Als ob es ein Grundproblem des Raumes wäre, gerade gute Laune zu haben oder laut zu sein. Als ob der Raum laut wäre, nur um dir das Telefonat zu versauen. Und dann ,,Autschuldigung, ich geh mal kurz raus, hier ist ein bisschen laut gerade", und dann raus. Ich liebe das. Noch nie ein unsympathischer Abgang gewesen. Ja, und dann kommt man wieder rein mit so einem Oh Leute, musste das jetzt sein Blick. Und man setzt sich hin und denkt sich, dein Handy hat geklingelt, du hast ein Telefonat geführt im Raum. Deine Schuld. Das ist wirklich ein Problem. Aber laute Räume, trotzdem müssen wir auch mal über das Problem laute Räume sprechen. Ja. Funktioniert nämlich für mich auch nicht gut. Beispiel Restaurants. In Deutschland sind Restaurants relativ leise. Kommt ein bisschen auf die Restaurants an natürlich, aber in beispielsweise Amerika ist der Lautenstärkepegel so unglaublich hoch, dass man sagt, ich habe echt Probleme, mich in einem amerikanischen Restaurant wohlzufühlen, gerade so in New York, weil es unglaublich laut ist und man sich wirklich nicht konzentrieren kann. Hast du das Gefühl, nicht? Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, weil in New York halt immer so ein bisschen Ausnahmesituationen war, was das andere ist, als wenn man jetzt jede Woche zusammen... Weil es per se lauter ist. Ja, weil der Kopf auch lauter ist, der Kopf ist lauter. Man hat weniger Ruhephasenbedürfnisse, sondern man will was erleben. Wogegen wenn du einmal in die Woche zu deinem Stamminder gehst, da nervt es sich dann schon, wenn irgendwie ständig da Rambazamba ist. Aber wahrerweise geht es. Vielleicht legt sich das ja aber auch nicht mehr, wenn du dann immer in New York wohnst. Das stimmt halt auch, wenn du es halt gewohnt bist, dass es laut ist und dann sprichst du auch lauter und dann gibt es nie den Punkt, wo man sagt, so, jetzt mal alle, alle Lautstärke halbieren, weil dann geht es ja wieder. Ich glaube, Thanksgiving. Alle fahren aus der Stadt raus, aufs Land, zu ihren Familien, kommen dann da runter, reden dann da viel zu laut. Du, Mama, kannst du mir das mal kurz geben? Und alle sagen, der Tisch ist das Korrektiv und sagt, nee, wir hören dich, wir hören nicht ganz. Und er sagt, oh, New York, sorry, New York, New York. Ja, okay. Und dann kommt Patrick zurück und redet ganz normal mit allen anderen.
Und die ganze Stadt war ein bisschen leiser.
Aber Lautstärke ist ja oft sehr, wird ja im Verhältnis oft wahrgenommen.
Ist ja auch oft so, was ich zum Beispiel mache, ist, wenn ich denke, okay, jetzt ist bei meinem Podcast oder Musik die Lautstärke okay, mache ich immer eine Lautstärke leiser.
Und dann gewöhnt man sich wieder in das Leisere und so kann man immer dafür sorgen, weil es gibt ja auch diese Aufwärtsspirale, dass, oh, wenn es gerade laut wird, mache ich einen lauter und man nimmt aber das nie wieder zurück, diesen Schritt, den man hochgegangen ist. Und ab dann ist es immer lauter und dann irgendwann ist es wieder lauter und so wird dann irgendwann dein Gehör kaputt, weil du dann eigentlich konstant zu laut hörst. Deswegen immer jetzt im Moment, nehmt euch mal jetzt die Sekunde und macht bei eurem Handy einfach mal einen Drücker leiser. Und wenn ihr denkt, oh, jetzt höre ich gerade gut, nochmal einen Drücker leiser, weil es gibt wenig Mechanismen, die es wieder runter regulieren, aber viele, die es hoch regulieren und dadurch macht ihr euch euer Gehör kaputt. Ja, das stimmt. Und so müsste es eigentlich auch sein, dass man einfach mal so im Zug, wenn sich so ICE, alles hat sich so hochgesteckt, einfach mal sagen, stopp, alle mal halbe Lautstärke und dann geht's wieder. Du bist, will ich, du bist, ich weiss, ich träume von sowas, ich mach's natürlich nicht. Kurz davor, zu einem unsympathischen Menschen auf der Welt zu werden, wenn du irgendwann der Typ bist, der aus einem lauten Zugabteil aussteigt, sauer ist, weil er einen Anruf bekommen hat und und dann zurückkommt und sagt, so, können wir jetzt mal alle, ganz kurz, stopp mal eben, oder auch dieses berüh selber im Weg, realisier deine Träume und ich denke mir immer so, nee, du willst nicht, dass ich so bin, wie ich eigentlich gerne sein würde, weil dann wäre ich ein riesiges Arschloch. Aber alle, alle Menschen, wie sie gerne sein würden, ist furchtbar. Ja, das einzige, was mich davon abhält, ein Arschloch zu sein, ist Angst und Scham. Und wenn ich die nicht hätte, dann wäre die Welt eine schlechtere, weil ich würde allen auf die Nerven gehen im Restaurant. Entschuldigung, können Sie leise sein? Entschuldigung, Sie telefonieren sehr laut, ist Ihnen vielleicht nicht aufgefallen. Sie essen so laut, schmatzen so laut, machen Sie mit dem Mund zumachen vielleicht. Entschuldigung, Ihr Kind schreit schon seit einer Stunde konstant, können Sie da vielleicht was dagegen machen? Und Dienstag in Köln sollte man vielleicht nicht Meeresfrüchte bestellen, naja, schönen Abend noch. Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, Sie standen vorhin beim ICE-Aussteigen direkt vor der Tür für mehrere Sekunden. Können Sie das vielleicht lassen? Können Sie das vielleicht nicht zwanzig Minuten vor Bahnsteighalt aufstehen? Das ist auch wieder unangenehm. Ja, es reicht, wenn Sie aufstehen, sobald der Zug in den Bahnhof einfährt. Habe ich selber getestet oft genug. Ja, so wäre ich, wenn ich wäre, wer ich wirklich bin. Seid froh, dass es nicht so ist. Seid froh, dass ich die dicke Maske der Zivilisation noch fest auf dem Gesicht spüre. Ja, und ich glaube, das ist auch richtig, dass Leute Masken auf dem Gesicht haben. Total. Aber ich finde gut, dass Leute dann irgendwie so, sei wer du bist und dein Blick in die Seele ist, die Pforte deines Glückes, bla bla bla. Und bei dir ist es einfach nur, nee, lass mal schön eure Maske auf. Genau, ja. Seid mal so, wie ihr nicht seid. Genau, nee, mach mal weniger, du selbst. Weil Kant hat es ja schon ganz gut getroffen.
Kann es denn zum allgemeinen Gesetz werden, wie du dich gerade verhältst?
Kann jeder so sein, wie er wirklich ist?
Nein, aber Kant hat es natürlich dann clever gemacht, weil er nicht, viele sagen ja,
komm, wir werden mal kurz philosophisch, weil viele sagen ja, dass der kardioische Imperativ ist,
wie du nicht willst, dass man nicht tut, dass wir doch keinem anderen zu, also das klassische
Die Goldsitzenden sind in der letzten Woche ein, der sich in der letzten Woche ein Viele sagen ja, komm wir werden mal kurz philosophisch, weil viele sagen ja, dass der kategorische Imperativ ist, wie du nicht willst, dass man nicht tut, das wird auch keinem anderen zu, also das klassische, die goldene Regel sei du, so wie du auch behandelt werden willst.
Der kategorische Imperativ ist aber das nicht. Der ist deutlich objektiver. Der sagt ja einfach nur aus, kannst du wollen, dass es zum Allgemeinen gesetzt wird, für alle anderen, der beträgt es ja nicht nur auf dich selber, sondern auch auf die Allgemeinheit. Und wenn sie alle so verhalten würden wie du, würde dann diese Gesellschaft noch an sich funktionieren, jetzt mal ganz platt ausgedrückt. Aber das finde ich halt deutlich cleverer, weil ich glaube, demnach würdest du ja auch nicht wollen, dass sich alle so verhalten wie dieser Typ, der in deinem Kopf rumschreibt, der pedatische Arschloch. Das willst du ja auch nicht wollen, dass sich alle so verhalten, wie dieser Typ, der in deinem Kopf rumschreit, der pedatische Arschloch.
Das willst du ja auch nicht. Es darf nicht zum allgemeinen Gesetz werden, dass so sich Leute verhalten, dass Leute so sind, wie sie sind eigentlich. Das stimmt. Ich glaube, es kommt aber noch schlechter, wenn du zu dem Rentner hingehst und sagst, schon Immanuel Kant sagte, dass sich jeder so verhalten soll, wie er möchte, dass sich alle verhalten können. Und sie standen leider drei Minuten lang vor der Tür und haben alle blockiert. Wenn das jeder tun würde, dann käme hier niemand mehr nach Hause. Okay, alles klar, hier ist eine Reklame, bitteschön, kann ich nicht geben. Oh, ich glaube, ich habe... Nee, ich sage doch nichts. Was denn? Ich sage doch nichts. Warum denn nicht? Nee, ich sage doch nichts. Oh, weißt du, ich kann dir was verratraten, weißt du, warum wir, na wohl, ich weiss nicht, du wolltest ja, dass wir nicht mehr sagen, wann wir aufnehmen, aber ich sag mal so, willst du wissen, warum wir heute Abend nicht aufnehmen können? Nee. Weil ich da zu Gast, nee, willst du nicht wissen? Nee, sorry, ich hab nicht auf die Verneinung, oh mein Gott, Herr Anwalt, seitdem du diesen Jura-Studiengang neben mir angefangen hast, willst du nicht wissen, seitdem ich Solmecke abonniert habe. Ich habe jetzt nicht auf die doppelte Verneinung in deinem Satz, in deiner Fragestellung geachtet, tut mir leid. Ja, ich würde gerne erfahren, warum du heute Abend nicht aufnehmen kannst. Gut, weil ich zu Gast bin bei einem Podcast, und zwar im Podcast von Joyce Ilk. Oh mein Gott, Joyce Ilk. Joyce Ilk hat einen Podcast und die haben die Joyce-Ilk-Geschichte sich angehört. Nein. Die Joyce-Ilk-Geschichte aus dem Podcast-Ufo. Eine ganze Folge lang haben sie diese Geschichte angehört. Eine legendäre Podcast-Ufo-Geschichte, wie ich damals beim Neo-Magazin noch Joyce getroffen habe, wie sie da zu Gast war. Und mich sehr schlecht angestellt habe und sehr, als er so eine unangenehme Situation kam. Ihr könnt euch anhören, gibt es auf YouTube als Ausschnitt und das haben sie sich angehört und im gleichen Zug haben sie die Einladung ausgesprochen, deswegen bin ich da heute Abend da. Wenn ich das mal früher gewusst hätte, heißt der Podcast und ja, es war sehr interessant, das nochmal wiederzuerleben und so diese Flaschenpost, die wir damals ins Meer geworfen haben mit dieser Geschichte, die jetzt über ganz viele Umwege, Jahre später, fünf oder sechs Jahre ist das jetzt her, die jetzt irgendwo bei ihr am Strand angekommen ist und diese jetzt aussagt. Aber das war vor kurzem erst, als sie das dann gehört hat. Das war ihr letzte Woche. Oder das ist zum ersten Mal gehört. Das ist aber krass. Ist auch krass weil wir immer dachten obwohl ich glaube die die die zielgruppen überschneiden sich nicht so stark gar nicht glaube ich aber zumindest haben wir so eine engagierte community vielen dank noch mal dass ich dann denken würde dass sie sich so eine joyce die kriegt jeden tag 50 nachrichten von hey guck dir mal das an guck dir mal das an da glaube ich geht sow Was natürlich gut war für uns lange Zeit, aber jetzt war es, es war sehr, sehr unangenehm, das zu hören. Und natürlich, wenn man über jemanden spricht und die Person es dann hört und ich wirklich im ersten Satz, ja, wer ist Joyce Ilk? Ja, Joyce Ilk ist so eine Amateurschauspielerin und sie pausiert und was meinst du mit Amateurschauspielerin? Schauspieler. Und du denkst dir so, oh Gott, das geht in eine ganz falsche Richtung.
Aber hat grossen Spaß gemacht, die Folge anzuhören.
Und heute Abend kann ich mich für alles entschuldigen,
vor allem für die ganzen bösen Dinge, die du über sie gesagt hast.
Was?
Sie hasst im Laufe des Bits immer mehr dich, weil du immer sagst,
ja, die ist aber auch echt dumm, oder?
Und sie immer so, warum sagt der das?
Das stimmt. Ganz Liebe, Herzensgute Natur und dann immer so, warum sagt der immer, dass ich dumm bin? Das ist in jeden Fall so lustig, ich kann nicht, ich versuche dich heute so gut in Schutz zu nehmen. Ja, das wäre super, weil man war halt da früher so, ich weiß nicht, so ein junger, war ich ja, war er 17 oder so, warst ja wirklich jung, also richtig jung. Ja, so in dem Dreh, ne, 19. Krass. Ja, da sagt man auch viel Quatsch. Kannst du dir ja mal entschuldigen. Ich entschuldige mich nicht. Das freut mich aber sehr. Das ist so ein bisschen so Closure. Es ist ein bisschen Closure, diese Welt, die endlich mal zusammenkommen. Jetzt ist vielleicht die erste Storyline, die dann endgültig abgeschlossen sein wird. Stimmt, endlich mal eine. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was du erzählst. Ja, die können wir auch mal einladen. Wir können immer generell wieder heute einladen. Ja, stimmt, wir haben lange keine Gäste gehabt, aber was wir dafür haben. Genau, wollte ich gerade auch eine neue Rubrik, die wir seit ein paar Wochen eingeführt haben, wieder zum Leben erwecken und weiterführen. Denn wir haben festgestellt, wir haben keine Ahnung von einem grossen Land südlich von Europa. Wir wissen nichts darüber. Ah, mittlerweile wissen wir ja, es ist nicht nur ein Land, es sind mehrere Länder mit verschiedenen Kulturen. 55 Länder, die sich zusammengetan haben, die gesagt haben, Freunde, wollen wir nicht mal gemeinsame Sache machen? Ich glaube nicht, dass es so funktioniert. Bolowien, nee, Afrika, ja, wir nennen uns Afrika. Aber die machen ja nicht gemeinsame Sache, die sind ja nur durch ihre ... Eigentlich müssten wir am Ende von Antenne Afrika, wenn wir alle Länder vorgestellt haben, nochmal so eine gemeinsame, so eine Afrika-Folge machen, wo man so gesamtafrikanische Aspekte noch macht. Das ist ja eben nicht United State of Africa, das ist ja einfach nur ein Kontinent, die einfach nur durch die Geografie miteinander verbunden sind. Aber wir hören mal rein, denn wir haben einen ganz, ganz tollen neuen Beitrag bekommen.
Und vor allem, wir haben ein Intro bekommen, und hier ist Antenne Afrika.
Wie nackt ein Steffen für dieses fantastische Intro, grossartig! Anten Aber Afrika ist nicht nervig. Weiß ich nicht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das möchte ich nicht sagen. Falls ihr Expertise zu einem Land Afrikas habt, die meisten sind noch offen. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass eure Expertise noch offen ist, ist relativ hoch. Ja, man klingt auch viele Nachrichten so, ja, welches Land ist denn noch über? Falsche Frage. Vertrau mir, noch genug. Quasi alle. Aber irgendwann wird es eng. Also ich glaube so nach der 54. Folge, wenn dann irgendwie noch Kongo offen ist und die Leute sagen, kommt schon, irgendwie seit Jahren suchen wir jemanden aus dem Kongo. Mal gucken, was das letzte Land wird. Dann müssen wir ja wieder hinreisen. Niemand will, dass sein Land das letzte ist, deswegen haltet euch ran und schickt uns Beiträge, wie es getan hat, liebe Amelie und die erklärt uns was über das dritte Land in der Antenne Afrika und zwar Tansania. Viel Spaß mit Amelinnen und Schülern bei der Morning Assembly der Monga High School. Wenn man sich auf dem Schulhof umdreht, kann man den Kilimanjaro sehen, der an der Grenze zu Kenia liegt. Dort war ich diesen Sommer für knapp zwei Monate als Educational Volunteer zu Besuch, da die MHS die Partnerschule meiner ehemaligen deutschen Schule ist. Man kann vielleicht auch schon raushören, dass das Singen der Nationalhymne hier an der MHS zur täglichen Routine gehört. Und das ist auch nicht ungewöhnlich für tansanische Schulen, da die Regierung dies verordnet hat, um die Verbindung Tansanias zu Afrika zu stärken. Ausserdem soll der Zusammenhalt und der Patriotismus in dem erst 55 Jahre alten Land gefördert werden. Genau wie die Hymne von Namibia aus der vorletzten Sendung ist Mungu Ibariki Afrika sehr friedlich und weitaus weniger aggressiv als viele europäische Hymnen. Mungu Ibariki Afrika heisst auf Soheili so viel wie Gott behüte Afrika, wobei das Wort Mungu, also Gott, sowohl von den Muslimen als auch von den Christen verwendet wird. Das vereint die Menschen der beiden Religionen natürlich sehr. Der Islam und das Christentum haben in Tansania ungefähr gleich viele Mitglieder. Beide haben einen im Alltag ziemlich friedliche und kulturell sehr ähnliche Lebensweise, auch wenn Religion eine enorm wichtige Rolle im Weltbild spielt und es fast keine Religionslosen gibt, sowie nur wenige, die eine Volksreligion haben. Ich durfte mehrere Male in die Moschee und in die christliche Kirche mitkommen. Das hat mich vor allem durch den sehr lauten und lebendigen Chor und die vielen Jugendlichen beeindruckt. Die erste Nationalsprache Swahili vereint das Land ebenfalls, und die zweite Nationalsprache Englisch verbindet Tansania mit dem Rest der Welt. Die meisten Menschen können zusätzlich die Sprache einer der über 130 einheimischen Ethnien sprechen. Der gesamte Unterricht an weiterführenden Schulen erfolgt aber auf Englisch, und das ist insbesondere für die jüngeren Schüler eine Herausforderung, da die Themen teils sehr anspruchsvoll sind. In den meisten Fächern der Mwanga High School erscheint mir der Lehrplan mindestens auf Abiturlevel und manchmal auch höher. Die meisten tansanischen Kinder besuchen Internate, weil sie dort besser lernen können oder auch einfach, weil die Entfernung von Schule und Wohnort zu gross ist. In den Internaten gibt es dann oft sehr strenge Regeln, aber die Gemeinschaft untereinander ist wirklich überwältigend, wahrscheinlich auch, weil die Kinder ihre Familien meist nur zwei Mal im Jahr sehen können. So finden die meisten in den Freundschaften einen Familienersatz. Das macht sich dann auch einer Sprache bemerkbar. Aussagen über Familienzugehörigkeiten, insbesondere über Brüder und Schwestern, meinen oft keine Blutsverwandtschaft, sondern weisen auf enge Beziehungen zueinander hin. Das hat bei mir am Anfang zu lustigen Verwirrungen geführt. Als ich mich zum Beispiel mit der Lehrerin, bei der ich wohnte, unterhalten habe, meinte ein Mitarbeiter der Schule immer zu mir, ah, I see you're talking with your mother. Für einen Aufenthalt in Afrika würde ich euch gerne den Tipp geben, Angebote wie Austauschprogramme, Auslandssemester, Kontakte zu Einheimischen oder ähnliches zu nutzen. So lernt ihr das Land nicht nur aus der Touristenperspektive kennen, sondern bekommt einen relativ realitätsnahen Eindruck von der Kultur und dem Alter, denn dieser unterscheidet sich oft stark von der touristischen Sicht und ist meistens aber viel interessanter. Das ist ja generell bei allen touristischen Aktivitäten der Fall, aber in Afrika habe ich die Unterschiede noch viel extremer erlebt. Zum Beispiel war ich auch auf einer Safari für Touristen und muss sagen, dass man die Kultur durch solche Aktivitäten in einer grundlegend anderen, sehr oberflächlichen und nebenbei viel teureren Weise kennenlernt. Außerdem würde ich jedem, der in den globalen Süden reist oder auch wie Stefan und Florentin einfach nur in Afrika interessiert ist, empfehlen, werft einen Blick in die kostenlose Internetbroschüre mit kolonialen Grüssen. Der Text klärt in einzelnen Kapiteln und Grafiken über unterbewusste Vorurteile auf. Damit hat er mir sehr geholfen, mich in der anfänglichen Reizüberflutung ein bisschen zurechtzufinden und die eigenen Gedanken zu reflektieren. Und wenn man so besser vorbereitet ist, kann man wirklich beide Seiten stark von einem Austausch profitieren. Eigentlich hat mich dort am meisten überwältigt, wie gastfreundschaftlich und offen mir die Menschen entgegengekommen sind, obwohl ich kulturell einen ganz anderen Hintergrund habe, was natürlich für die Tansania und mich eine Herausforderung war. Wie ihr merkt, bin ich riesiger Fan von Tansania und hoffe, dass ich euch das einzigartige Land etwas näher bringen konnte. Jetzt weiterhin noch viel Spaß mit dem Podcast-Ufo. Kua-Heli! Ah, Kua-Heli zurück, Amelie. Vielen Dank für diesen fantastischen Beitrag. Freut uns sehr. Amelie aus Tansania. Das heißt, wir können fortsetzen. Achtung, ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und merke mir Namibia. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia und Uganda. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und merke mir Namibia, Uganda und Tansania. Sehr gut. Noch ist es leicht. Noch ist es leicht. Ich habe gerade noch mal ein bisschen herausgefunden, denn wir haben auch viele Nachrichten bekommen, weil wir uns mal gefragt haben, wo spielt denn jetzt König der Löwen? Unser Klischee, und es ist Tansania, es spielt nämlich in Serengeti, im Serengeti der Savanne, Serengeti, das wird ja auch relativ offen. Da geht man offen mit um. Da man offen im Film mit um und im Norden, das ist der Serengeti Nationalpark und der erstreckt sich im Norden Tansanias, das ist das Viktoriasees, über 30.000 Quadratkilometer. Das ist ein Nationalpark? Das ist ein Nationalpark? Ja, jetzt haben Sie, wo haben die das in uns gedreht? Das stimmt schon, da kriegst du ja kaum Dreherlaubnisse in der freien Natur. Nee, genau. Also Serengeti-Nationalpark, mittlerweile ist es das. Aber wenn du Serengeti googelst, dann ist halt einfach auch König der Löwen-Stimmung schon mal angeseitigt. Ja, ja, ja. Tansania ist interessant, es gibt auch die Insel Sansibar, von der ja, wo der Freddie Mercury herkommt. Das weiss ich auch wieder nicht. Das ist ja in Sansibar, meine ich, aufgewachsen. Ist es an der Küste Tansania? Ja, es ist eine Insel. Also Tansania hat, glaube ich, viel zu bieten. Tolles Land. Auf jeden Fall. Ich finde, Amelie hat auch viele gute Punkte angesprochen. Und sie war da anscheinend zu Besuch als Aufenthalt. Kilimanjaro ist der größte Berg Afrikas. Aber gibt es da nicht, wie heißt es dieser... Die Kaiser-Wilhelm-Spitze. Ach Gott, überall die Deutschen, wie ein fucking Stempel. Ja, aber die Engländer, die haben da... Ja, ja, aber... Ich meine, wir haben es unglücklicherweise alle die, wo die Deutschen waren, als erstes abgehandelt. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es auch kein Zufall, wenn man da wahrscheinlich auch am ehesten hinkommt dann. Ich glaube auch, ich glaube, man muss trotzdem damit aufräumen. Wir müssen auch mit unseren kolonialen Vorurteilen aufräumen.
Grosse Sorry auch nochmal nach Tansania. Ja, richtig, sorry, war nix. Aber spielt nicht auch Roadrunner in Tansania? Also so dieser, dieser, wie heißt der denn, dieser tansanischer Teufel?
Ah, wie heißt der denn? Tasmanische Teufel, ganz anders, ganz woanders. Das ist Tasmanien, oder was?
Tasmanien. Ist das auch in Afrika? Das ist was ganz anderes. Da habe ich mich jetzt komplett blamiert. Australien. Ach Gott, da habe ich mich blamiert. Schön ins Fettnäpfchen gesetzt. Mit Anlauf. Aber gut, Roadrunner ist also in Australien, nicht in Afrika. Ich dachte auch, das sei Afrika. Nee, aber auch gut, dass wir das mal aufklären. Wunderbar. Der Tasmanische Teufel Tasmanien ist ein Bundesstaat Australiens. Okay, gut, hat nichts mit Afrika zu tun. Ja, wir haben schon einige weitere, wir haben noch einen weiteren Beitrag, aber wir brauchen auf jeden Fall noch mehr. Und ich glaube, wenn da jetzt wirklich zwei gute Beiträge aus demselben Land kommen, dann werden wir nicht einen wegwerfen. Dann können wir beide Beiträge zeigen. Und von den Folgen, die gelaufen sind, wisst ihr ja, was passiert ist.
Von daher, beeilt euch, um noch
schnell die besten Länder, die besten Länder sind
noch da, sag ich mal. Ja, genau, nicht, dass am Ende noch
die Grütze über ist. Die dicksten
Kirschen hängen noch am Baum,
pflückt sie euch runter.
Das war Antenne Afrika. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, dass dieser Trainer wieder alles einreißt, was wir an Klischees, nee, wieder alles aufbaut, was wir an Klischees einreißen möchte. So rum. Ja, nächste Woche freue ich mich sehr darauf, Beginn unserer Live-Tour 2019-2020. Einen Termin machen wir ja noch in diesem Jahr, nämlich nächste Woche sind wir in Stuttgart, nächste Woche Montag. Freue ich mich sehr darauf, ich war noch nie in Stuttgart, glaube ich, bewusst. Ich auch nicht, wirklich. Ja, genau, man hört viel, aber ich war noch nie persönlich vor Ort. Ich freue mich sehr darauf und freue mich darauf, alle zu treffen, die dort auch sind in Stuttgart. Auf jeden Fall. Wird eine Reinkommashow? Wird eine Reinkommashow, wir müssen es mal abtasten, sind wir noch drin, können wir es noch, konnten wir es jemals, diese Fragen. Und dann machen wir jeden Monat wieder eine Show ab nächster Woche, freue mich sehr darauf. Genau, ansonsten ist nächste Woche eine ganz normale Woche. Ansonsten nichts anderes. Das. Eine rote Enttäuschung. Es ist eine Woche mit sieben Adventskalendertürchen, das ist klar. Ah, ja, ja, ja. Hast du einen Adventskalender? Ja, ja. Oh, soll ich noch einen mitbringen, habe ich vergessen. Mir wurden zwei geschickt, vielleicht aber auch dir, ehrlich gesagt, von unserer Agentur. Habe ich bekommen, habe ich vergessen, aber falls ja eine für dich war. Habe ich schon aufgemacht, aber den ganzen Adventskalender in einem Anfall. Ich habe nämlich ja, weil ich mich bewusst ernähre, habe ich mir ja keine Süssigkeiten, kaufe ich mir mehr. Ich habe nichts Süsses in meiner Wohnung. Aber jeder hat ja Bock auf was Süsses, ist ja menschlich, ist ja in dir drin. Und dann hatte ich halt diesen Adventskalender da und der war weg. Nach zwei Stunden in der Wohnung war der weg. Boah, das ist aber schon, da muss man schon echt skrupellos sein. Warum? Der Blick, den du mir gegeben hast, als du die Schildkröte umgedreht hast, den gebe ich dir jetzt zurück, weil das finde ich skrupelloser, an einem Tag einen ganzen Adventskalender zu vernichten. Und einfach sagt, mir ist völlig egal, was die Dächtigkeit ist. Und es war noch nicht mal Dezember. Alter. Ich habe im Supermarkt wieder den After-Aid-Kalender gesehen, der Big Ben, der Turm, wo dann so After-Aid-Sachen drin sind. Aber da habe ich ja so ein bisschen ein Problem mit... Morgen! Wir sind bald durch, zehn Minuten, wir sind zehn Minuten durch. Darf ich jemanden grüssen? Ja, Raphael darf jemanden grüssen. Hey, ich grüsse Sascha aus Heidelberg. Hey, tschau! Das ist Raphael, dessen Büro wir gerade hier in Beschlag nehmen. Dann darf man auch grüssen. Dann darf man als einziges mal grüssen. Ich habe in Afterhead so ein bisschen meine Liebe gebrochen, weil ich hatte dieses Heizungsproblem. Ich stelle alles auf die Heizung und ich hatte auch schon viele Adventskörner, die ich aus Dummheit... Und der Big Ben ist ausgelaufen. Genau, aus Dummheit auf die Heizung gestellt ist und dann ist der Big Ben ausgelaufen und alles tropft dann so unten durch, tropft an der Heizung runter und dann hast du dieses warme Pfefferminzschokoladegeruch in der Wohnung und seitdem kann ich mich mit After-Eight nicht mehr so gut anfreunden. Deswegen ist der Weg dann raus. Hast du eine wohlriechende Wohnung? Ja, was heißt wohlriechend? Es ist ja, manche Dinge werden ja, fallen dann wieder um in Negativ. Ja, warum ist es zu vieles? Diese Erfahrung habe ich mit Marienkäfern gemacht, weil ich war mal im Urlaub an der Ostsee und da war eine grosse... Zu viel Marienkäfer. Es war, ich habe Marienkäfer mag. Jeder liebt Marienkäfer. Kann dieser Hund mal die Fresse halten eigentlich? Ach Gott, ein Cutter-Kollege hat jetzt auch einen kleinen Hund. Ja. Keine Hunde in der Urlaub. Aber der stinke nicht. Alles gut, der Hund ist super. Der ist winzig. Genau, aber dann... Jeder mag Marienkäfer auf der ganzen Welt. Jeder liebt diese kleinen Dinge. Und es ist auch nicht, dass man kaputt schlägt, die rettet man, lässt man fliegen, freut sich, ist ein bisschen traurig, wenn sie wegfliegen, weil man sich schon lange gewöhnt hat. Auch rassistisch, ne? Also die Fliegen schlägt man kaputt, Moskitos und Marienkäfer, die sind orange, haben süße Punkte drauf und die sind so rund und süss. Und die Tiere, die gab es an der Ostsee zuhauf, da gab es nämlich eine Plage. Und dann habe ich wirklich, und das ist, es war erschreckend, wenn man überlegt, wie schnell es umschwingt, also wie schnell der Mensch einfach von süsser Marienkäfer hin zu mit diesen Beachballschlägern, kennt man diese Holzschläger, einfach auf so ein orangenes Meer draufhaut und man einfach so hunderte Marienkäfer getötet hat. Aber es was heißt Plage? Wie viele waren da aktiv? Milliarden. Der Strand war teilweise orange, weil tausende, Millionen Marienkriege waren. Das ist da schief gelaufen. Kann das sein, dass ein Jahr plötzlich ganz viele sind? Da ist irgendwas schief gelaufen. Vielleicht auch, weil die ein Überernahrungsangebot hatten oder so, weil es eine andere Plage davor gab. Das ist ja sehr empfindlich in der Tour. Aber das war wirklich, vielleicht weiß noch jemand, was für ein Jahr das war, ich weiß es nicht mehr, von ein paar, ungefähr so vor zehn, zwölf Jahren. Und da ist man dann, sind alle am Strand ausgeflippt und Tamarienkäfer umgebracht. Daran sieht man mal, wie schnell der Mensch kippt. Also von sorgsam hin zu mordlustig. Wahnsinnig. Krass. Aber hat auch schon ein bisschen Spaß gemacht. Wenn man die Erlaubnis bekommt, jetzt mal einfach Tiere auszuräumen. Auch für seine eigenen Gewissen die Erlaubnis zu bekommen. Ja, befreiendes. Sind wir nicht unsere grössten Käfig? Sind wir nicht der wahre Käfig, der in uns... Ist unsere Moral nicht der wahre Käfig? Also wenn die einfach das tun, was wir eigentlich tun.
Ist nicht mein ...
Der Fakt, dass in diesen Zitaten nie ein Äh oder so drin ist, fasziniert mich auch wahnsinnig.
Ja, skeptisch, mache mich skeptisch.
Ja, es gab doch auch in Irland oder so dieses große Schlangenkloppen, wo dann alle einfach mal einen Tag alle Schlangen kloppen dürften.
Ja.
Dann gab es einfach in Gesamtirn einfach keine einzige Schlange mehr.
Weil die, ich glaube, der Zerstörungswut von Menschen ist so dermassen effektiv, dass wenn der mal entfesselt wird, dann ist wirklich alles weg. Also man müsste irgendwie dann, keine Ahnung, irgendwie mal Plastikmüll oder so entfesseln und sagen so, ihr müsst das Plastikmüll kaputt machen. Aber das bringt halt auch nicht viel. Nee. Das knirscht so. Keine Lust, es stinkt, dann wird man nass. Naja, das ist schon nervig. Massenmord ja, aber ich will nicht nass mehr. Ich will einfach nicht nass mehr. Ich bin gerne nass, ich habe nichts dagegen, nass zu sein. Ich habe irgendwie so nirgendwo an die Leute, es regnet und alle rennen irgendwas über den Kopf. Aber das ist auch eine Frisur, das ist auch eine Frisur, die scheißegal ist. Ich finde, fast alle Frisuren sehen besser aus, wenn sie nass sind. Es gibt zwar extra so Haargel, das dafür sorgt, dass du aussiehst, als wärst du nass. Finde ich grauenhaft. Was das Dümmste ist, was man überhaupt nur machen kann. Weil jeder weiß, der ist jetzt nicht acht Stunden lang nass im Büro, der hat irgendeinen Scheiss drin. Jeder sieht, nee, du bist... Unnatürlich, unnatürlich, unnatürlich. Neben ihm der Pedant steht neben ihm und sagt, das ist unnatürlich! Aber ist ja nicht schlimm, der Mensch hat ja die Natur überwunden. Hat er das? Hat er, hat er die Natur überwunden. Das weiß ich noch nicht. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich habe die Natur noch nicht überwunden. Wenn ich ein Eichhörnchen sehe auf der Straße, hinterherlaufe. Du hast zwei perfekt geschliffene Gläser auf dem Kopf, die dafür sorgen, dass deine naturgegebene Blindheit korrigiert werden. In der Savanne wärst du tot. In der Savanne wirst du sagen, was ist das da? Warum hört man eigentlich nie von kurzsüchtigen Menschen im Mittelalter? Ja, weil die tot sind. Hatten ja schon Brillen auf. Einfach gestorben. Aber es doch alle Menschen heutzutage kursichtig. Kann natürlich auch mit, ja das hängt vor allem aber auch, das habe ich dir schon erklärt, mit den kurzen Augen zu tun, dass wenn du zu viel im Haus bist, zu wenig im Sonnenlicht bist und oft zu nahe Dinge fokussierst, dann werden deine Augen kurz. Im Mittelalter, was hast du denn angeschaut? Einen Burgturm, ganz weit weg im Freien, ein Berg,
irgendwie ein nahendes Heer der
Osmanen oder sowas. Und du hast immer in die
Ferne geschaut. Und dafür sind die
Augen da. Die Augen sind ja...
Ja genau, schieß dich da hinten, ist
Ziel, 30 Meter entfernt. Die Augen sind ja in der
Savanne entstanden, wo du den Horizont absuchst
nach Feinden. Und wir, wir gucken immer
20 Zentimeter vor uns auf irgendwas.
Dafür sind die Augen gar nicht ausgelegt. Deswegen werden die Augen zu kurz und dann wird man, dann kann man nicht mehr so gut sehen. Kann ich jetzt meinen Augmuskel trainieren, indem ich mir häufiger wieder in der Savanne, in der Serengeti zum Beispiel stehe und an den Horizont gucke? An alle da draußen, damit eure Augen nicht zu kurz werden und damit ihr das korrigieren könnt, in der Sonne weit wegschauen. Im Hellen weit wegschauen. Es ist völlig egal, was ihr im Dunkeln macht, es geht um Sonnenlicht, es geht auch nicht um Lampenlicht, macht das Licht an, wenn es dunkel ist, vollkommen egal, es geht nur um Sonnenlicht, weit weg schauen. Wenn ihr im Zug fahrt, schaut euch die Wolken an, fokussiert weit entfernte Dinge, aber Zug ist auch nicht gut, ihr müsst schon in der Sonne draußen sein. Okay, also der eine Tipp, den du gerade gegeben hast, war auch wieder nicht anwesendbar. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich halt auch viel meine Aktien mir geholt, weil ich wusste, dass jetzt ganz viele Leute Brillen brauchen. Korrigieren, kann ich es denn korrigieren, wenn ich jetzt schon... Wenn du es rückgängig machen kannst, weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich glaube, es lohnt sich, damit die nicht noch länger werden, damit du nicht irgendwie wie Bender irgendwann da sitzt und kürzen willst. Kürze hast du doch gerade gesagt, die werden zu kurz, wenn du bist nicht zu lang, du widersprichst dir. Keine weiteren Fragen, liebe Jury. Ja, irgendwann sind die so kurz, dass du nicht so, dass du nach innen guckst. Keine weiteren Fragen. Dass du gar nicht mehr nach außen schauen kannst, sondern nur dein Gehirn siehst den ganzen Tag. Und dann denkst du dir auch, ja, Leute, darauf kann ich auch verzichten. Sehr gut. Gut, nochmal ein schöner Tipp hinten raus. Wir wünschen euch eine fantastische Woche. Wen wir in Stuttgart sehen, freuen wir uns auf euch. Kommt vorbei, haut rein. Ansonsten...
Tragt unsere schönen neuen Socken nach Stuttgart vielleicht im Auftritt.
Vielen Dank an alle, die an dieser heutigen Folge mitgearbeitet haben. Es waren Steffen, dann natürlich Amelie für ihren Beitrag und Daniel für das Intro.
Florentin hat gesprochen.
Ja, und Stefan war auch dabei. Vielen Dank dafür. Macht's gut, haut rein, bis nächste Woche.
Macht's gut, wir haben ab. Ciao.